vous demandez simplement d'arrêter de mentir
aux gens sur le changement climatique et
sur la pollution et de leur proposer
des solutions plutôt que des océans parce qu'en
fin de compte, peu importe combien d'argent
nous gagnons ou combien nous gagnons dans une carrière
et comment  nous deviendrons successifs, mais ce qui
est important, c'est combien nous
redonnons à la communauté et j'ai toujours
voulu redonner et pour moi, il a
toujours été important d'élever tous les
sports et d'inspirer les gens du monde entier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique  ]
[Musique]
la vie dans les affamés
reste affamé ceux qui sont loin hanumanasan
Finlande et c'est pourquoi il y avait tant de labels
philosophie
[Musique] il
y avait des moments où les gens disaient qu'ils ne
pouvaient jamais se faire qu'un garçon de ferme autrichien
puisse venir en Amérique et  entrer
dans l'industrie du cinéma et
réussir dans l'industrie du cinéma, ils ont
dit que nous ne pouvons pas prononcer votre nom, vous
ne parlez pas bien anglais et votre
corps est trop développé et vous savez ce qui
s'est passé, je suis devenu l'artiste le mieux payé
au monde
[Musique]
Je veux atteindre  à tout le monde trop
jeunes et vieux gens riches et pauvres de
toutes religions toutes couleurs et toutes
nationalités Je veux être le gouverneur
pour les gens Je veux représenter
tout le monde
[Musique]
c'est plus grand que n'importe quel film c'est
le défi de notre temps ce  c'est pourquoi je
suis en croisade pour inverser cette tendance
et créer un avenir énergétique durable
et déterminer le changement climatique
une fois impliqué
[Musique]
un forage Rosa mais vous savez
des situations comme le scandale qu'ils ont
créé qui a séparé ma famille  et
c'est très pénible de traverser ça et d'en
parler et de raconter tous
les détails
[Musique]
il n'y a pas d'eau conservatrice dans l'eau libérale,
nous buvons tous la même eau, alors
éliminez la politique et arrêtez de
pointer du doigt et mettez-vous vraiment à
affaires et vraiment faire la croissance des gens
[Musique]
il est comme The Terminator vous savez qui
veut mettre fin à tous les progrès il
veut mettre fin à tout
espoir pour l'avenir
[Musique]
si nous n'agissons pas, c'est leur  l'avenir en
jeu n'est pas le nôtre,
leurs rêves devraient nous donner l'espoir que leur
vision devrait nous conduire à l'action et je
tiens à remercier Greater et en tant que jeunes
héros du monde entier pour avoir partagé
leurs grands rêves quand ils vous traitent
de râpe folle, rappelez-vous simplement continuez
don '  ne les écoute pas parce que sensé rappelle-
toi juste que les gens sensés ne
changent pas le monde mais tu le feras